And I,
and if I read philosophy,
I tend not to read second rate
philosophy,
and so I've tried to avoid the
postmodernist system degree because
they're,
they're incoherency is one of the least
of their sins,
but they don't care about that.
No,
no.
You've got to understand,
man,
the modernists and enlightenment people
and even traditionalist who care about
coherency,
the postmodernists don't believe and
coherency.
They don't believe in.
And I'm,
I'm not making this up.
This is part of their philosophy.
They don't believe in logic.
You know,
Derrida says straight out that Western
society is fallow logo centric by which
he means male centered and privileging.
The idea of logic.
Well,
he doesn't buy any of that.
He doesn't think that there is a truth
that's out there.
He doesn't believe that individuals can
reach any sort of truth by thinking.
He certainly doesn't believe that we can
move towards truth in dialogue because
that's dialogic,
right?
There's none of that.
You wonder,
well,
why do the,
why did the postmodern types keep other
thinkers off the campus?
Well,
it's not because they're afraid.
so some of them are,
but they used their fragility as a mask
for their,
you know,
the underlying philosophical,
their underlying philosophical and
political interests.
They do that fragmentary.
It's not like every social justice
warrior is a sword carrying port
postmodernist,
but the ideas are fragmented and
distributed among them like they're
distributed among a mob and if you put
the whole mob together,
you get the whole post modernist thing
happening at the same time and that's
how ideas have people instead of the
other way around.
Anyways,
forget about logic that's out the
window.
That's just a construct of Western
society and and the whole point of the
construct was to oppress other people
and to take their wealth and to
privilege the people who live within
that so called logic system so that they
can justify to themselves and other
people their Predator rapaciousness
straight and simple and that's partly
because postmodernism was influenced by
Marxism and of course that's what the
Marxists.
Think about any situation where there is
a,
let's call it a power status
differential.
The people at the top are only there
because they've stole everything from
the people at the bottom.